en france cela fait maintenant deux mois
que la petite estelle a disparu à la
sortie de l'école à guermantes en
seine-et-marne deux mois et malgré une
très forte mobilisation toujours aucune
piste sérieuse
ce matin une banderole humaine a été
déployée au départ du semi marathon de
paris
une initiative de l'association estelle
qui veut encore y croire
sophie guillemin et christophe hillary
aidez nous à retrouver estelle ce
message 14 mille coureurs ont pu le lire
ce matin sur la ligne de départ du
marathon de paris
ce sont les proches de leur petite fille
disparue il ya deux mois jour pour jour
qui ont une idée d'associer ainsi
symboliquement leur combat à la
manifestation sportive est quand même de
grandes similitudes entre une course de
fond
il me raconte
combat puisque
l'effort va durer la distance
l'acharnement et
buts à atteindre la ligne d'arrivée à
franchir cette ligne d'arrivée les
proches des stèles ou tout essayé depuis
deux mois pour y parvenir
campagne d'affichage dans les rues les
aéroports les gares création d'un site
internet publication d'un avis de
recherche par plus de 500 entreprises
rien n'y a fait les initiatives doivent
donc se poursuivre le but c'est de ne
pas renoncer fait que l'on considère qu
est ce qu elle est certainement quelque
part qu'il nous faut la retrouver et qui
a peut-être des gens qui ont des
informations qui peuvent être n'ose pas
encore
sépare donc diffuser le être être
présent diffuser l'avis de recherche ses
droits lors de leur dire à nouveau
on a besoin de vous un appel à l'aide
d'autant plus pressant que l' enquête
semble piétiner perquisitions à grande
échelle fouille systématique de
véhicules et autres interrogatoires de
suspects n'ont mené nulle part les
parents de la petite fille ne dispose à
ce jour d'aucune information qui leur
permettrait même de deviner ce qu'est
devenu leur enfant depuis qu'elle a
disparu
en sortant de la boulangerie de
guermantes le 9 janvier dernier